on a
utilisé les mesures qui étaient
proportionnelles et nécessaire pour
pour empêcher ces manifestations
illégales de continuer à perturber
l'économie et surtout la vie des gens
qui demeure convaincu qu'il avait les
motifs nécessaires pour invoquer la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence en février
dernier afin de mettre un terme à
l'occupation du centre-ville d'Ottawa
une commission spéciale qui doit
maintenant déterminer si c'est vraiment
le cas alors à quoi est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre des six prochaines semaines
de travaux ce qui a un risque pour le
Premier ministre d'être éclaboussé par
tout ça voyons voir ce qu'on pense mes
collaborateurs avec qui est absent cette
semaine c'est Madeleine lemorel la chef
du bureau politique de Radio-Canada à
Ottawa qui est avec nous à ses côtés
vous les connaissez Chantal Hébert
chronicard au Toronto Star et magazine
L'actualité Michel serrogy chroniqueur
politique à la presse plus la
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour bonjour on commence avec la
visite la vieille habitude de Madeleine
commençons avec vous à quoi est-ce que
on s'attendent ces audiences mais je
pense qu'on a déjà eu un aperçu à dès la
toute première journée à quel point les
opinions sont divergentes sur la
justification est-ce que c'était
justifié ou non d'invoquer la Loi sur
les mesures je vous entendais Daniel
dire Justin Trudeau est convaincu mais
il n'a pas convaincu tout le monde il y
a il y avait des sondages de ce
printemps qui disait qu'il y avait la
moitié à peu près des Canadiens qui
croyaient que qu'invoquer la loi c'était
justifié donc là on va entendre des
provinces par exemple l'Alberta par
exemple la Saskatchewan dire c'était pas
justifié puis en plus juste intrudo
n'aurait pas dû invoquer la loi parce
qu'il aurait dû nous consulter d'abord
ce qui l'a à peu près pas fait il y a
des groupes de défense des libertés
civile qui disait bon la menace n'était
pas assez grande pour invoquer la loi il
y a la Police provinciale de l'Ontario
qui disait les pouvoirs prévus dans la
loi était superflue donc vous voyez on
va entendre ça d'une part puis on va
entendre d'autres parts le gouvernement
notamment le gouvernement fédéral des
ministres dire non au contraire il
fallait cette loi-là c'était
proportionnelle c'était justifié on a
déjà entendu Justin Trudeau le dire mais
ultimement il va falloir convaincre
parce qu'il y juge Roulot à convaincre
mais il y a aussi l'opinion publique à
convaincre donc ça va être aussi un
exercice de communication de la part du
gouvernement pour essayer peut-être de
d'expliquer davantage pourquoi cette
loi-là à leurs yeux aux yeux du
gouvernement étaient nécessaires bon
Michel ensuite Chantal Michel il y a
quand même un risque pour Monsieur
Trudeau là-dedans et un risque aussi
pour d'autres parties je présume
bloqué et n'oublions pas la question
laquelle le juge ruleau doit répondre ce
n'est pas est-ce que c'était utile
d'avoir la loi des mesures d'urgence
pour mettre fin à la situation des
camionnettes la question c'est si
c'était justifié c'était nécessaire et
ça c'est beaucoup plus haut comme bar à
franchir voilà le gouvernement tout le
monde est d'accord
ça a marché c'est sûr mais en même temps
est-ce que c'était le seul moyen de le
faire et c'est ça qui est beaucoup plus
difficile à prouver pour pour le
gouvernement et on verra dans l'esprit
du juge Roulot c'est que les défenses du
gouvernement ont fait mais
c'est une barre qui est très haute c'est
faut pas l'oublier la loi qui a remplacé
la loi des mesures de guerre c'est un
bel exercice que d'avoir ça après pour
justement te justifier ça n'a pas été
fait à 70 ça peut être fait quand on est
un paquet en mesure de guerre mais ça
existe quand même pour le gouvernement
un niveau de preuve bien au niveau de
capacité de convaincre qui est très
difficile le risque là-dedans
il y a un risque certain une partie de
la réponse va venir de l'information que
des experts services de sécurité et
autres on donnait aux conseils des
ministres ça peut pas être seulement des
impressions que il fallait faire quelque
chose parce que dans ce cas-là ce serait
évident que ce serait une réaction aux
pression politique qui vous le savez
c'était multiplié à un moment donné
néanmoins c'est important pour l'avenir
parce que la barre et autres et elle
doit rester haute pourquoi elle doit
rester haute quoi qu'en penses le
gouvernement aujourd'hui parce qu'un
jour les mêmes gens qui vont vous dire
c'est un Trudeau avait raison seront
peut-être pas d'accord quand on va
appliquer la même méthode et que le
gouvernement serait conservateur et
qu'on parlera d'un blocus autochtone
alors il faut que l'argumentaire du
gouvernement soit solide cela dit il y a
quand même des risques limités dans le
sens où c'est pas l'impression moi qui a
un gros avantage pour Pierre poillière
l'Empire scénario pour le gouvernement
de juge ou l'eau à la fin du finalement
c'était un raccourci il y aurait eu
moyen de faire autrement je vois pas
comment pierre pollière chef
conservateur aspirant Premier ministre
pourrait passer plusieurs jours à
triturer le gouvernement et a donné
l'impression que finalement il y avait
raison d'épouser la cause du convoi
parce que l'opinion publique est
peut-être ambivalente sur la loi des
mesures d'urgence mais elle est
certainement pas ambivalente sur le
convoi lui-même et les taxiques employés
il y a des photos de Monsieur pollière
avec une boîte de bains qui vont revenir
rapidement avec un chien
Michel c'est très court quand même ce
qu'il a comme comme période le juge
rouleau 6 semaines pour faire le travail
est-ce que est-ce que c'est suffisant
ça devrait être suffisant il est quand
même pas obligé de retourner chaque
paire de soins procès au criminel cela
c'est une
jugée des explications du gouvernement
et des explications d'autres
intervenants dans cette crise là et de
voir il y a des choses là-dedans qui
reprendront pas beaucoup de temps à
se faire comprendre par exemple le
combat ambassadeur il était déjà ouvert
quand on invoqué la loi alors ça c'est
une chose qui sur lequel il y aura pas
besoin de passer énormément de temps
alors il a le temps de faire le travail
c'est fastidieux remarqué et puis c'est
là aussi cela quand vous êtes le juge
que vous écoutez chacun des arguments
mais ça se fait les enquêtes
là même les plus compliqués
je pense que il y a beaucoup de gens
surtout en Ontario qui ont trouvé
curieux néanmoins que le gouvernement de
l'Ontario soit aussi absent de cet
exercice là oui parce que la dernière
fois qu'on a regardé
Ottawa
c'est bel et bien dans la province de
l'Ontario au pense à one ou en Alberta
et l'essentiel de cette crise là c'est
passé en Ontario mais l'impression que
ça donne c'est que le premier ministre
Ford veut pas jouer dans ce film là
d'aucune façon même pas pour donner un
coup de pouce ou un coup de pied à
Justin Trudeau
probablement parce qu'il sent qu'il y
aurait peut-être des risques pour lui
aussi il y a pas un acteur dans cette
crise là la crise du convoi des
camionneurs qui est pas un peu sous qui
est un peu menacé ou bien qui qui peut
subir un peu sur la défensive avec cette
question là quoi que pour Justin Trudeau
parce que c'est lui entre autres qui va
devoir des témoigner et pas pierre
poilliev mais je trouve quand même
intéressant de noter que jusqu'à
maintenant les questions portent
véritablement sur est-ce que c'était
justifié ou non d'invoquer la loi c'est
des questions qui sont fondamentales
parce qu'on veut pas justement qu'on se
servent de cette loi-là de façon trop
facile mais en même temps on n'est pas
en train de se poser des questions sur
des dérives qui ont eu lieu à cause de
l'utilisation de la loi sur une mauvaise
utilisation de la loi une fois qu'elle a
été finalement utilisée je trouve que le
risque aurait probablement été plus
grand pour Justin Trudeau si ça avait
commencé à aller travers après
l'invocation de la loi
on n'est pas allé chercher
l'opposé des intellectuels de Ville
d'Ottawa ou de la région de l'Ontario
pour les mettre en prison c'est quand
même une grosse différence par rapport à
la Loi sur les mesures de guerre et
l'application de la loi a été
extraordinairement limité dans le temps
dans le sens où même le Sénat selon mes
souvenirs on va pas eu le temps de se
prononcer ou c'est avant que ça soit
fini alors quand même nature on peut
dire d'autre part ce qui va aider le
gouvernement quelque part c'était qui
était minoritaire donc ce serait pas
arrivé s'il y avait pas eu la pluie d'un
autre parti pour le pour appuyer la
démarche à la Chambre des communes
Michel qu'est-ce que vous avez
surveiller des travaux qui s'enviennent
il reste presque 6 semaines en fait il y
a eu seulement deux jours là
la voix des acteurs politiques là-dedans
a commencé lors de ce Trudeau et
justement va être obligé de dépasser la
phrase qu'on a entendu au début de dire
ah ça vient de faire et tout ça il va
falloir qu'explique pourquoi le
gouvernement le fait ça j'ai hâte de
l'entendre parce que c'est pas toujours
très bon là-dedans pour pour ceux que ça
intéresse les politiciens normalement je
pense qu'ils sont prévus plus tard dans
le processus vers la fin alors on va
devoir faire preuve d'un peu de patience
on va faire un saut du côté de Québec
cette fois-ci parce que c'est pas passé
grand chose cette semaine on a beaucoup
été dans la réflexion mais monsieur
Legault qui la dernière fois qu'il a
parlé aux médias parlait de choix
déchirants qui leur est à faire pour son
conseil des ministres du commencer à
réfléchir à ces choix-là alors
maintenant je vais attendre vers vous
qu'est-ce qui émerge de ces discussions
là c'est très secret encore il y a
personne qui a reçu l'appel mais quand
même il y a des noms qui circulent il y
a des rumeurs qui circulent en même
temps dans ce genre d'exercice là les
gens qui savent se taisent et les gens
qui savent commence à parler de toutes
sortes de rumeurs de nom qui circulent
c'est pas nécessairement une bonne idée
de dire ah moi j'ai été approché et je
vais être ministre dans tel dans tel
ministère ce serait probablement une
recette pour finalement être exclu de ce
genre de poste là c'est un problème de
riche en cas François Legault mais c'est
un problème quand même parce que avec un
plus grand nombre d'élus il a un plus
grand nombre de choix mais aussi un plus
grand plus grand possible de faire des
déçus parce que les gens qui ont la
confiance de mettre leur visage sur un
poteau sur une pancarte aussi parfois la
confiance de se voir éventuellement
ministre et non seulement il y a des
gens qui veulent avoir un rôle de
ministre mais parfois même un rôle
précis dans un cabinet ministériel je
pense par exemple la joie
elle avait été déçu de perdre son poste
de ministre de la Justice puis ça a mené
à une crise au sein du gouvernement
Trudeau donc c'est un exercice qui est
difficile pour François Legault surtout
que il y a pas tant de place que ça là
lors du dernier du premier cabinet
Trudeau il y a seulement deux personnes
qui avaient des expériences
ministérielles François Legault
Marguerite Blaye et là c'est pire là si
on exclut des gens tout d'un coup ça
fait des gens qui se voient vivre une
dévotion et donc encore plus grande
déception donc calculs politiques qui
est complexe pour François Legault
Chantal effectivement calcule pas simple
pour monsieur Legault en même temps que
j'ai à l'abondance aussi il y a pas mal
de monde et il y a beaucoup de candidats
intéressants
qui parlent avant et qui risque de se
faire éliminer ou tasser à cause de ça
on peut se demander si les gens qui ont
raconté qui étaient question d'un super
ministère économique pour monsieur fait
du cabin on n'a pas voulu quelque part
de faire tribucher dans le sens où
produit des un avertissement de la PDG
d'Hydro-Québec
sa place à la tête la société était pas
acquise qu'elle n'allait pas rester si
elle avait des commandes qui allaient à
l'encontre de ce qu'elle perçoit comme
le meilleur intérêt du Québec et
d'Hydro-Québec alors c'est intéressant
je dois vous dire que dans plusieurs
officines on surveille un poste c'est
évident c'est celui qui s'appelle
Ottawa les relations
intergouvernementales qu'un autre nom à
Québec probablement des relations
canadiennes mais ce ministre ce
ministère là le job de Sonia Lebel dans
le dernier gouvernement exactement on se
demande Sonia Lebel des bonnes relations
avec beaucoup d'élus sur l'aquarium
parlementaire fédérale et au sein du
gouvernement Trudeau mais on se demande
est-ce que est-ce qu'on va se ramasser
et c'est l'expression qu'on utilise avec
Simon Jolin borax
et si c'était le cas ce serait
interprété comme
un signal qu'on s'envoie vers une
période extraordinairement mouvementée
et pas nécessairement
particulièrement productive au niveau
des relations interware au Québec
ça pourrait donner le temps à une
relation plus confrontationnelle mettons
Michel qu'est-ce que vous voyez vous
dans ce qui se dessine il est défi de
Monsieur LEGO
problème il a très clairement une équipe
qui est meilleure que celle qu'il avait
il y a 4 ans de y avoir il va y avoir
des déçus mais en tout cas à tout
prendre il est mieux dans cette
situation aussi qu'il y a 4 ans
souvenez-vous bien de parler level à un
moment donné elle avait 400
pas beaucoup de sens non plus alors ça
je pense que ça va être fini ce qu'on
sait c'est que le haut de la pyramide
sera pas touché c'est-à-dire le duo
économique qui est de Monsieur fédigabel
eduise des finances monsieur Gérard on
verra l'étendue des pouvoirs de Monsieur
freddievin chasser d'accord et Chantal
il y a eu des coups de ce monde cette
semaine qui ont peut-être changé les
affaires mais aussi du B qui va rester
là le plus gros budget de l'État son
deuxième étage il va y avoir des
changements d'éducation transport à
travers
l'immigration sécurité publique des
migrations c'était cet acquis qui va
changer ça c'est là il va y avoir de
gros changements et c'est là qu'on rien
à voir
l'écart entre les ceux qui restent et
ceux qui entrent les recrues
là-dessus il pourrait y avoir des des
déçus pour pas que ça paraisse trop à
Québec on leur a dit vous serez sermenté
au début de la semaine et député puis
après ça on commencera à faire des
téléphones pour dire qu'il est ministre
comme ça au moins quand ça va passer
tout le monde va être content et
dimanche prochain on ira faire le tour
des vrais nominations puis on regardera
ce que ça donne puisque ça veut dire
pour les relations fédérales de c'est
intéressant là je vais surveiller Simon
j'en ai barrette à Ottawa je vais voir
quel genre de réaction ça cette semaine
merci beaucoup à la semaine prochaine au
revoir